say one general preliminary thing about
this wonderful event and it is that we
had Nick Montfort and I at MIT had been
thinking about a forum devoted to the
electronic embodiments electro -
electronic experiment digital
experiments in literature and mmin and
as we began to speak about that of
course the speakers who are on today's
panel jumped to our minds first and
originally the plan was simply to have a
forum devoted to the topic of our final
session this afternoon
electronic literature and future books
but when when I got word of the
existence in within MIT of these gifted
and wonderful young colleagues the our
wonderful organizers of this conference
we got together and we began to talk
about expanding the event and and and
that's the event that's come here and I
wanted to mention this in part because
both Rita and Kate Hales were very
accommodating to us by agreeing for one
thing at a fairly late stage after
plants had been made to postpone their
arrival by a day and to take part in the
full day's discussion my hope and my
expectation is that you'll find today
this this final forum in some degree
returning to some of the themes that
have already arisen in in our discussion
today and also to extend them into areas
that we haven't yet touched upon are as
many of you surely know our speakers
today are among the pioneers in the
territory of digital creativity digital
literature they will speak in the order
in which I will introduce them each
speaker will follow the format we've
been using earlier although all three of
my speakers have promised me that they
will stay within their time limits to
give us time for a rousing discussion
and I hope we will have that
they will each speak for a brief time
and then we will open the conversation
to all of you our first speaker is one
of the great figures in this emerging
field Katherine Hayles as she's a
professor of literature and co-director
of the John Hope Franklin humanities
Institute at Duke where she's taught for
some time and her distinguished books
include electronic literature new
horizons for the literary my mother was
a computer digital subjects and literary
texts and most recently how we think
digital media and contemporary techno
Genesis Katherine will open the
discussion with the presentation and she
will be followed by Rita ray Lee who was
associate professor of English at the
state at the University of California in
Santa Barbara where she directs
transcriptions an online publication
devoted to the digital humanities she's
the author of tactical media electronic
mediations and co-editor of the
electronic literature collection vol 2
with several other Co editors and as
anyone who's interested in the field
knows both Kate's work and and Rita's
work is very widely cited and has been
already very influential our final
speaker is one of mi t--'s most luminous
newly tenured young young faculty
members Nick Montfort and Nick's
imaginative work has already in some
respects transformed comparative Media
Studies at MIT he's an associate
professor of digital media here and
president of the electronic literature
organization he's written widely about
and created many digital media projects
and among his publications are REME a
500 page poem written amazingly in one
day
his latest book riddle and bind contains
literary riddles and constrained poems
as he describes them he's also the
author of twisty little passages and
approach to interactive fiction I will
begin then with Kate thank you David for
that introduction and I too wish to
thank the organizers of our conference
apophenia a lovely word that means
finding patterns in random data
it marks the territory of conspiracy
theories it defines the province of
paranoia and it names the risks endemic
to literary criticism on occasion it can
also serve as a stimulus for artistic
creativity and it as it did with William
Gibson in his book pattern recognitions
and as it has for David Clarke in his
net art piece 88 constellations for
Vidkun Stein this is the opening screen
you can see it's a Mercator like
projection of constellations as you
mouse over the various constellations
threads appear defining the threads that
connect the different stars and then you
can click on one of those stars to enter
the constellation constellation is an
interesting metaphor here because
ancient peoples looked in the sky and
thought that the groupings of stars
define mythical figures but astronomers
know that the stars named in those
constellations have no necessary spatial
contiguity nor do they have any
necessary relationship so constellations
are a very ancient form of finding
patterns that the data themselves do not
justify so among the patterns that David
Clarke suggests in his work
are these the number 88 there are 88
constellations but also there are 88
piano keys Vidkun Stein's brother lost
his right arm in World War 1 and he
previously - that was a concert pianist
after losing his right arm he began to
commission pieces for the left hand and
you can trigger some animations in this
work using your left hand on the
computer 8 also names H as the eighth
letter of the alphabet one of the
episodes is about the fact that German
soccer teams don't use the number 88 on
their jerseys because 8/8 could be read
as H H which in Nazi circles would mean
Heil Hitler
and then imagine 88 line on its side it
now becomes infinity doubled so this
gives you an example of how different
facts are being put together into
threads with a suggestion of patterns so
let's take a look at one of these AIDS
April 1889 and you'll see this
constellation includes stars on Charlie
Chaplin Adolf Hitler and so forth
these are count your lucky stars Ludwig
Wittgenstein Charlie Chaplin and Adolf
Hitler were all born in April 1889
within days of each other the [ __ ] the
dictator and the thinker three stars to
set the compass of 20th century history
by ludwig was born into one of the
richest families in Europe but he gave
all his money away Charlie was born into
a poor theatre family in London and made
his enormous fortune in the flakes
Hitler was middle-class all the way
Ludwig Wittgenstein and Adolf Hitler
went to school together in 1904 after
two of his older brothers committed
suicide it was decided that Ludwig
should be allowed to venture outside the
confines of the glittering fantasy
active it can stein palace and into the
real world and that is how he came to
the real schooler in Linz a Technical
High School that allowed him to pursue
his enthusiasm for engineering and all
things of mechanical and as it happened
the young Adolf Hitler was attending the
same school the school where he would
whet his appetite for anti-semitism
Hitler wrote in mine camp at the real
school to be sure I did meet one Jewish
boy who was treated by all of us with
caution and perhaps just perhaps this
Jewish boy was Ludwig Wittgenstein the
stuttering assimilated Jew the son of
wealth and privilege who had a
propensity even then for
indiscriminately confessing his sins
other episodes here point out the fact
that Charlie Chaplin made the film the
Great Dictator and in which he played
both the surrogate for Hitler and the
Jewish barber who stands in as a double
for Hitler and the Chaplin had a
particular grudge against Hitler because
he felt that he had stolen his mustache
another episode points out that Hitler's
grandfathers our grandmother served as a
maid in the Baron Rothschild household
she discovered that she was pregnant so
there's the suggestion that there may in
fact have been Jewish blood in Hitler's
own family line he was concerned enough
about that descended attentive to find
out if it was true so you can see here
the way that the episodes work there's a
voiceover which mostly relays facts and
then the cultural context is largely
given to us through the images and the
annotations
8:8 is of course a double number and
we'll see the interplay between those
facts and
the way the images work in this playful
difference after the first one could
still believe it was an accident
only the second attack
terrorists attack his cottage in Ireland
a neighbor came by and was surprised to
find myself so there are too many
illusions in this episode to Vidkun
Stein's work for me to completely
elucidate them but you may have noticed
in those double squares that appear in
the centre in the background is the
famous shower scene from psycho we see
John at Janet Leigh who had a double in
that scene taking the shower and then
Anthony Perkins approaching vaguely we
can see him through the shower curtain
another episode is on Anthony Perkins
and points out the fact that he had a
double life in a double sense that he
was identified with Norman Bates his
most famous role and in that sense he
was double but he had another double
life because in an age of homophobia he
was gay and he had to try to project the
image of a heterosexual leading man in
1991 Anthony Perkins died of AIDS ten
years later his widow is on the plane
that flies into the Twin Towers
so the Twin Towers also appear in this
episode in another episode they're
linked to the obelisk in 2001 what's the
difference between coincidence and
science repetition but here we have a
focus only on the double so we're riding
along the edge of apophenia and proof in
this equivocal figure that you see here
the two female faces animated to appear
to be talking to one another we get that
linked with the Vidkun Stein anecdote
and in philosophical investigations
Vidkun Stein argued that the meaning of
a word is in its you
so broadly construed we could say that
Clark here is working with the voiceover
as facts but it's the contextualization
of the images and the animations that
give those facts specific meanings
within this work now let's go to a star
in another galaxy far far away David
Marx ins print novel Vidkun Stein's
mistress the sole character in this
novel is a protagonist we know only as
Kate and Kate believes that she is the
last person in the world and she sits
day after day typing sentences that
occur to her on her typewriter and these
sentences constitute the novel here's a
sample the young woman is asleep in a
painting in the Metropolitan Museum
she's thinking of a painting by Vermeer
she saw there's something wrong with
that sentence - of course
there being no young woman either but
only a representation of one which is
again why I'm generally that I delighted
to see the tennis balls so you can see
the radical dis junctions here between
these paragraphs that seem to make no
sense and yet as we continue to read
this narrative we begin to get some
hints about why Kate is in this
condition either as a fantasy or as an
actuality
seems to have something to do with the
death of her son and her subsequent
separation from her husband whose name
she can only intermittently remember so
from a certain point of view we could
say that Kate is trapped in the
Tractatus that Ken Stein's first early
work Vidkun Stein later came to doubt
the wisdom of the positions he argued in
the Tractatus which proposed that logic
could be used to solve most
philosophical problems much later and
posthumously Vidkun Stein wrote
philosophical investigations in which he
argued that there were only language
games and that these language games
acquired meaning owning only in their
social and biological
chuckle contacts so Kate's belief that
she's the only person in the world
literalizes the impossibility of a
private language that Wittgenstein
asserted in philosophical investigations
if the meaning of language is in fact in
social context and their words no social
context there was only a single person
then language could not have any meaning
at all but of course we as readers
recuperate that language as a as a
reading community and we struggle to
find a pattern amidst Kate's meditations
so now putting constellations and
Mistress together what kinds of patterns
might we see well in those
constellations images serve as context
in the novel they're represented through
a crisis the verbal representation of
visual phenomena in constellations it's
primarily the animations that create
connections between these coincidental
events and therefore suggest patterns in
Mistress the paragraphs are
disconnections
and it's only as we read on through the
narrative that we ourselves as readers
begin to construct the threads that
might constitute a pattern so we can say
that constellations begins with
fragments and builds towards some
elusive hole while the novel being a
novel begins with a presumption of some
kind of coherent whole
but shatters that by breaking the text
into fragments so my conclusion is this
that each of these works becomes
resistant and experimental within the
tradition it they have located
themselves so for David Clarke working
in the tradition of net art which is
often fragmentary viewed for a few
minutes by visitors to a museum
installation for example he begins with
fragments but he rewards readers who
stayed with him by suggesting there is
an elusive hole that we nevertheless
can't grasp
articulate Markson working in the
tradition of the novel defeats that
tradition by breaking it into fragments
but then allowing readers to imagine
these threads do connect into some kind
of explanation of Kate's condition in
other words we can understand these
works as resistant experimental works
only within the traditions in which they
work mode of analysis that I've
elsewhere called media specific analysis
that's the pattern that I see
but then again perhaps I myself am
suffering from apathy Nia thank you
[Applause]
sorry I just have to find my powerpoint
actually it was loaded for me but I
don't know where do you is the person
who did the loading available sorry to
cut into our time well while this is
happening let me just start by thanking
like sorry while this is happening let
me start by thanking David for including
me on this panel I'm honored to join
such illustrious company as as Katherine
Hayles and Nick Montfort and of course
let me thank amaranth and Gretchen for
their hard work on what is not only a
well-organized conference but a well
designed conference so I'm going to
start now I lost sorry I needed also my
well ok what I was going to do to start
was actually just read or navigate this
text ian Hatcher signal-to-noise so that
my initial remarks would be more
meaningful so what you could imagine is
that if I were reading I would be
mousing over these highlighted words and
what would be revealed to me our paths
options that I could take pursue and so
forth and then the narrative would start
to unfold at the bottom of the screen ok
I begin to read explore play with Ian
Hatcher signal-to-noise part vignette
part interactive fiction clicking the
highlighted keywords bottle cobweb and
exploring the bifurcated paths each
makes available open it leave it before
noticing what seems to be the result of
a scripting error at the bottom of what
is demarcated as page space a mishmash
of letters and partially realized words
in the darkest shades of grey is barely
perceptible upon closer inspection
almost immediately fading into the black
background suddenly however the error
seems to be an actual glitch the ghostly
characters become unmoored animated the
letter forms multiplying and more
quickly oscillating between states of
visibility and in visit
fading shifting position dissolving the
words that might have been back into
letterforms
the schematic structure of the text
move the mouse reveal the read early
choices is unsettled by these textual
ripples something is happening to the
text something has disturbed it it takes
a few seconds in a scan of the info page
to realize that it is not some thing but
someone who is entered into and is now
directly affecting my reading space
which is no longer mine alone I did not
elect to listen to the radio but someone
has someone not present but telepresence
if on the initial passage through the
text I looked out the window onto a
horizon to find an empty sea the
solitary aspect of my work confirmed by
the mirrored surface that reflects only
my own image now I am in the presence of
another reader the sea is no longer
empty and another boat another reader is
moored not far away this person and I
are in short reading together
concurrently in real-time I have not
encountered a text that bears the
vestiges of readings past marks both
discursive and physical vestiges or
footprints left by those who have come
before my reading is instead
synchronized with another's less in the
sense of coordination than liveness
aliveness that as Phillip Outlander
reminds us cannot be stabilized
practically or ontologically as either
live or mediatised but is rather both
and there is an improvisational quality
to the textual counter and in textual
encounter and hatch or signal-to-noise
what will happen if I open the suitcase
but the encounter of the other reader of
other readers is a script that once
identified can itself be read what is
coded into the text then the structural
logic that has to be materially
recognized before a successful reading
can be accomplished is the sociality of
reading but the question is how or to
what extent is it differently social
from print reading practices from the
whole host of clubs associations and
interpretive communities that have been
developed to decode make sense of and
importantly to share the experience of
reading books and other documents on the
face of it the message of
signal-to-noise reading is an inherently
social practice might be regarded as
familiar and even reiterative enacting
in thereby materializing an idea that is
already known to us but I think it is
rather the case that absent a live
socket connection the simulation of
concurrence in simultaneity such that
they are experienced as actual is itself
generative it's one thing to encounter
the traces of prior readers and quite
another to recognize the Co presence of
other readers unexpected unseen but not
on felt in such moments latency the
temporal lag that we accept is axiomatic
for our online engagements seems to have
been eliminated the gap between action
and response closed and the potential
for strange disturbing and otherwise
wonderful inter subjective encounters
opened more concretely consider the
narcissists 'm tallinn Mehmet's
neologistic formulation for our
fetishistic attachment to the enclosed
circuits linking the human subject in
the computational apparatus the
interface here is mirrored surface
narcissists UM's
as Memon explains privileged local space
/ emotional attachment selfish
constructs that position the subject as
island rather than nodal point of
networked communication circuits if
there has been a conceptual turn in
electronic literature at all within the
last decade my suggestion is that it has
been from the lamentations celebration
and critique of such narcissists UM's
human and machine coupled in a terminal
embrace to an articulation of systems
writ large matrices have distributed but
interconnected nodes entities bodies
devices that are as much about the nose
themselves as they are about the flows
among them
matrices then that are at once mediated
and lively in Contra distinction to the
narcissist em then signal-to-noise
foregrounds roam a promotional
attachments those formed as a
consequence of recognizing making
oneself available and responding to the
other readers the entity other entities
contained within it liveness as I'm
outlining it here is one of at least
three aspects of the sociality of
reading in our contemporary media
ecology another would be the social book
so it's fortuitous that I'm following
Bob Stein the social book collaborative
production or distributed authorship
Network novels in which it is not simply
the case that user contributions are
mined as source texts but that the
temporal frame of collaboration is
continuous sender and receiver remains
spatially and temporally distinct but
there is a sense in which the textual
contributions do not lie inert waiting
to be used but are rather part of an
ongoing dynamic exchange among readers
and authors the third aspect of reading
is context the third aspect of reading
as contemporary social practice more
directly bridges electronic literature
and the book and so here I will note
that I'm making a tracing a path rather
from electronic literature to the
unbound book the development of online
reader forums such as those for mark
Daniel F skis House of Leaves and only
revolutions and Steven halls raw shark
text these forums in which the books are
quite rigorously discussed
collaboratively interpreted and
collectively produced as cultural totems
in this context a discussion thread is
no mere guide or map with which to
navigate a distinct textual object the
forums are not conceptually stationed
outside the book proper not belated or
posterior to but are in no small measure
mutually constitutive in other words
they're not parasitic but rather
symbiotic indeed it's not for nothing
that Daniel s key should have a
dedicated
tell yeh to assist with his present
project the familiar for all of the care
devoted to the production of these books
house of leaves only revolutions raw
shark text etc for all the care devoted
to the production of these books that I
note as singular material objects their
layout and design their incorporation of
visual elements their exploitation of
the resources of codex they are in fact
expanded books their discursive fields
extending beyond page and spine unbound
in this other sense books that encompass
negative chapters books that encompass
negative chapter still to be produced
much less discovered translations and
adaptations to film or even opera that
are themselves and folded within the
expanded field of the book the expanded
book is not Codex not digital not game
not conversation not collaborative
content creation but that which is
situated in the interstitial field
Rosalind Krauss in her definitive
statement on sculpture in the expanded
field notes that quote we had thought to
use a universal category to authenticate
a group of particulars but the category
has now been forced to cover such a
heterogeneity that it is itself in
danger of collapsing unquote no such
diffusion or definitional collapse
results from the articulation of the
expanded book because it's imagined
expansion as well as as as well as its
imagined destruction is dependent on the
idea of the book as its very condition
of possibility
the expanded book the cumulative effect
of that which it is not the knot codex
not digital not game not conversation
not collaborative content creation is
already an abstraction even as it
maintains a tenuous flexible link to the
material substrate out of which it
emerges the expanded book is an
abstraction but I would say a productive
one because it allows us to think across
media platforms genres
and to conceive of the expanded book in
terms of reading and writing practices
put another way the unbound book here
for here reformulated as expanded is not
about ordinary rending or exclusively
about transcription or remediation but
it is also importantly about another
kind of unbinding a categorical
untethering in opening up toward the
sheer variety of reading and writing
practices that are not formal aiza
Balazs either book or electronic
literature we know well that codecs like
cinema and singles and the single screen
theater is no longer the exclusive or
even proprietary vehicle for the
transmission of its content the book
then is one component part of our
contemporary textual environments the
book in its expanded field but no less
significant or singular for being such
poce the new aesthetic the book codex
like other analog media such as cassette
tapes and super 8 film is a richly
productive site for creative
experimentation and play the expanded
book on the other hand is a richly
productive site for critical exploration
like the shadow text of signal-to-noise
it is ephemeral lively and vernacular
both common and held in common it is in
short where reading and writing is
actually taking place thank you
[Applause]
you currently attending the desktop I
can easiest for you to go all the way to
the left
actually thanks a lot
that didn't seem to improve things great
deal
as for the dick can you hear me I
apologize for the technical glitch but I
forgot to make a technical announcement
when I first introduced our speakers I'd
like to do it now while nick is trying
to fix this computer someone in our
group has lost an olive-green l.l.bean
hooded raincoat if you see it pick it up
and take it to the registration desk out
in the atrium thank you
it's locked up again okay
okay I'm gonna go ahead and put this
just give me a loan okay extended
desktop would be fine okay so let me go
ahead do this
oh okay
all right yeah yeah that's right just a
temp to my fate
okay all right
I apologize for the delay freedom
sometimes has its price I'm gonna speak
about this project ten print chartstring
205.50 and one go to ten it's a project
that I've collaborated on with two
others at MIT me Patsy Pavan and Noah
Vawter and the other individuals named
here there's ten of us that have written
a book about this one-line basic program
for the Commodore 64 what does it do
this is the this is the cover the book
that's coming from MIT press in November
so to figure out what this program does
it's helpful to know what the characters
at 205 and 206 look like they're they're
left-leaning and right leaning diagonal
line and then oh that's great let's see
here if we actually were to start an
instance of the Commodore 64
and run it we would see what happens in
response which is a production of a
pattern that looks like a random maze
and so you can see that the complex
rhizomatic networks of textuality might
be the topic that reader le is
discussing and the 88 constellations
related to Vic and Stein might be what
Kate Hales has talked about I can't do
88 constellations but I can do 38
characters of code for the Commodore 64
if I get nine other people to help me so
this is a program that you're invited in
the original sources where it is
disseminated to to modify to to change
and this program is running on a
Commodore 64 out in the lobby and you're
invited to come and do that yourself
with it let me return to the this
project and there's there's just the two
major things about it that seem unusual
to other people for some reason that it
is focusing on a single line of code why
would one write about a single line of
basic and that it's a project by ten
authors written in a single voice so to
try to give a context for what
programming was like around 1982 I wish
to share with you an Australian
commercial actually just the first nine
seconds of it so please don't blink as I
started that is a commercial for the
Commodore 64
and I think wish to share was the right
way to put that so that's a big
disappointment but the the context of
this program that I'm that I'm looking
at that my collaborators are looking at
is that of creative computing a category
that includes video gaming electronic
literature digital art but also these
things that don't even have a term or a
name hobbyist programming and
recreational computing a term that was
in use here at MIT in the late 1950s and
early 1960s so this is this is a program
that it's it's difficult to sort of
categorize what it is I think the best
common answer the the one that I've
heard today I mean it's not a piece of
productivity software you know it's not
a video game you can't you can't play it
you can't interact with it it looks sort
of like a screensaver but that's and
that's a good answer but it's one that
is a historical because the screensaver
hadn't been developed in 1982 no one
ever suggested that this was a program
to preserve the phosphor display of your
system and it wouldn't be a very good
one because it's putting one of two
characters in every position on the
screen so what might it be
I like the answer concrete poem but I
haven't heard that one yet
it's a some type of aesthetic production
that's being generated automatically and
it's a very very concise program to do
this it's a way to think about what our
categories are conceptual categories
about computing are how people got
involved with computers if people hadn't
been doing things like this with
computers at any point in history no one
would have thought to create ebooks it
just wouldn't have occurred to anyone
because computers would be used for
military scientific billing purposes but
not for cultural purposes and not for us
that it can not for literary purposes so
that's one of the ways that the system
is engaged with the specifically the the
issue of the book here you see two
different emulators with a program has
been started and a screen
has been taken in both cases and one of
the things you might notice is that the
pattern is exactly the same even though
it's a random maze it's one that is
actually deterministic the program does
not change the seed at the beginning you
get you can receive the generator off
the timer but it doesn't do that so you
get actually the same thing and this
question of randomness is one that we
can examine in this system we can also
think about questions of the material
artifact of the Commodore 64 out in the
lobby versus the emulator and what does
it mean to have an emulator in what ways
our emulators useful or not I think of
the emulator as a software addition of a
computer and I find that useful way to
think about it because there are
additions that are good for different
sorts of things some of them are
scholarly critical varioram there'd be
reasons that you would want to have a
particular addition for use in teaching
and then you know reasons that you want
to actually look at the material
artifact of of an early system just as
you would an early book here's a great
book this is a million random digits by
by the RAND Corporation very appropriate
name for the corporation that that
produced this influential document very
important document to providing a source
of randomness when there was not it was
not it was not easily available a random
number generation was not easily
available otherwise so I also recommend
I there's some really good reviews of
this on Amazon and I suggest you you
read them but the thing about this is
that you can see here in the book itself
is it doesn't look like you'd say well
is this entirely random
well no it's it's arranged in a grid I
mean everything it's actually in a
framework of regularity and ten print
the program that we've examined
uses randomness to select a
right-leaning or left-leaning diagonal
line but the fact of the grid the way
that everything is framed is very
essential to its overall effect and the
fact that the computer runs at the same
speed and that this process moves ahead
regularly is all
important to this effect so the balance
between randomness and regularity in the
play between those two is significant
int in print and it's something that
occurs again and again in
non-computational art all sorts of
digital art and literature gaming and
and other sorts of uses of computing so
this is line as a way into all of that
this is the first occurrence of a
program that functions like the tin
print program of the title in print I'm
brandishing the book now in which it is
printed the Commodore 64 users guide
from 1982 and one of the things that's
interesting about this is that you are
encouraged to modify the program and
this is a book that comes with every
Commodore 64 that is sold early on it's
not something special for programmers or
the elite this is another occurrence of
this tin print program a print there is
this is a little item that runs in the
in the magic section of run magazine
July 1984 and this is the magazine and
here you can see it circulates the way
this this one-line program gets out to
people is in print in a magazine in a
book that's the way people learn about
code like this and it would be quite
obvious for someone to keep this in mind
go to school or another context and
share the program from memory as well
these aren't ways that we think of
programs being circulated we think of
people memorizing poems and we think of
people you know printing and circulating
literary texts but not computer programs
and yet it did happen and we can see the
same thing with Pro one liners and other
short programs that continues to happen
today so here's a program that isn't
interactive it it does not accept input
from the user during execution it does
not have comments or even variables that
might be named significantly by user if
we wanted to interpret someone's
intention based on that we can't do it
in this case it doesn't have a known
author it just has a corporate author of
Commodore
it has no clear obvious purpose or
category that we could identify in terms
of the way we think of computing
nowadays but all of the things that it
allows us to engage the process of
iteration and how that works and what
influence it has in computing how to
generate two-dimensional effects from an
essentially one-dimensional process
that's just going and wrapping around
the screen randomness and its
counterpart regularity as I mentioned
the use of character graphics and
specific character sets in this case an
extended version of ASCII called pet ski
unofficially called pet ski that was
present on several different Commodore
computers basic and high-level languages
basic developed at Dartmouth in 1964 by
John Kemeny and Thomas Kurtz and then
implemented by Microsoft for the Altair
and actually the version of basic that
you were just seeing work and that was
going on out in the lobby is one written
by Bill Gates himself and actually
specifically adapted from his 6502 code
by Rick Weiland so that's how this
reached people who were Commodore 64
users users have the most the most
popular best-selling single model of
computer ever used ever ever made and
the role of the c64 on platforms is also
something we can investigate through the
look through looking at this as I
mentioned the transmission of programs
and questions about mazes and patterns
and their use in computing and in
various places in the arts so that's why
we're doing the project to sort of
excuse it even though I can't deploy a
great insight about it the book is
coming in November and it hopefully will
will satisfy that need
why have ten authors get together and
write in a single voice so one of the
things that that I would say about this
is there's plenty of sort of massively
authored books or ten authored books but
they're edited collections generally and
what happens then is you get a bunch of
people together who
know a great deal about a topic they're
experts in the field they know the
scholarly history but they don't talk to
each other as they do their work they go
off to stereotypically a library Carol
and and they work individually and after
the book comes out then they say oh you
wrote something for that too didn't you
and we want to do something different we
want to actually have people converse
and bring their expertise together in
the project so that's part of the idea
how we did it specifically was using
some very conventional means and some
slightly more recent means we had a
mailing list and we did a lot of
communication on email and here we had a
lot of the higher-level discussion or
sort of musing about topics which may
not have manifested themselves at all in
the final book but were part of our
thinking process about it we also used a
media wiki and I should mention that you
know we didn't use this in the sort of
free-for-all in the sort of imagined
free-for-all Wikipedia mode of put this
up and let people from the public come
in and say whatever they like and do
things work in whatever order of course
Wikipedia has its own hierarchies but we
did have plenty of ad-hoc hierarchies in
this project to assign particular people
to be the lead writer for a chapter
other people to review a chapter that
was that it was being worked on so we
had internal stages of review and other
types of attention on specific details
within within particular chapters
particular sections in particular
remarks as some of our interstitial
chapters are called so my work has
involved both academically and in my
creative practice a great deal of
collaboration I'm not even including the
editorial collaboration which is more
conventional but I've worked with
several people including Kate Hales and
no award of ruin and and others on on
editorial projects collaboratively but
actually co-creating a text and working
to produce a single art of
or book or project I've done in a
variety of different ways with different
collaborators and different
configurations and mmin many productive
things about this personally and I think
in terms of the quality of the work and
particularly whether one's looking at
specific technical details of the Atari
2600 which would be very difficult to
find someone to fact-checked if you
didn't have another collaborator who is
working through that with you or if
you're writing for instance a 2002 word
palindrome and the ability individually
to fall into insanity in doing this is
very great but with a collaborator you
can figure out which of the text is
actually meaningful should be pursued
should be revised it should be worked on
should be worked into the final text
this isn't the only project that has
many writers producing book in a single
voice in fact it's not only it's not the
current one in it's not the only one in
the current MIT press catalog so so I
wanted to mention this as a topic for
conversation and as a something related
to the way that books might be produced
in the future not just academic books
but other sorts of books that perhaps
there's a range of collaborative
practices not only the massive and
crowd-sourced sorts of practices and not
only the typical romantic
individualistic model but many things in
between that might be productive ways to
think together and write together thanks
very much
[Applause]
so we're now going to throw the
conversation open to the audience and I
hope you'll draw on your experience this
after in earlier sessions as well as you
pose your questions many of the speakers
who spoke earlier also should be
available here someplace and I hope that
many of you will will kick in as well
we'll take part as well while we're
waiting for questions let me start with
a very naive and and and perhaps
simple-minded one Nik about the project
you described it was hard for me to
understand why I would want to read your
book what what's it about what top
what's its subject so yeah I'm the the
rough start there probably hindered me
in explaining what what might in fact
not not interest you in any case but the
project is to look at creative computing
and to do that through the example of
this one line program to understand how
it was transmitted how it was typed in
understood by programmers why people
were pleased with the effect that
officials and the each of the
contributors is doing in the equivalent
of a kind of close reading of the of the
well all of us are doing that together
although it wouldn't be a close reading
in the sense of bracketing off
historical and biographical and
technical contexts so we're doing an
intensive reading but but not a new
critical close so you're aiming for a
thick description this is
so and it's the type of book that you
know we see books about single works of
art in fact there's a series that one
work series that MIT press distributes
about single works of art here we have
something that we don't even know what
it's name is when we see a work of art
we know what a gallery is we know what a
museum is we know what the art world is
we have actually much more to describe
about the context of hobbyist computing
so there's even more of a reason to take
that close focus we ready for questions
yes questions for Katherine little
louder be sure you use the mic and
identify yourself please
my name is Mathew rebury I teach at the
University of London and this questions
for Katherine I've been thinking about
how many print books have had a lively
afterlife through their adaptation into
other media so taking a nice century
novel and turning it into film a stage
play or an audio book and I wondered if
the electronic text you're working with
are equally susceptible to adaptation or
is there intensely media specific nature
somehow changed that question or even
the fact that they're using so many
different media it's hard to think about
work like 88 constellations for example
being made into a book because the
animations are so much a part of the
work it's also hard to imagine it being
made into a movie because the
fragmentation of the various episodes is
so intrinsic to its effect but I I would
draw here on Rita's idea of the expanded
book or the expanded field for works
like this so there is a lot of
commentary on the web for example on
this work and it may ripple out into
various transmedia narratives that
aren't this work as such but are
alluding to this work that's the way I
would see it propagating the perfect
example here would be a work of net art
Olli
my boyfriend came back for the war which
becomes remediated even in the form of a
t-shirt yeah and there's this project
like Jeff Raymond's 2:53 which is
originally on the web and then published
as a novel I mean that's not very
unusual overall to see certain web works
whether they're electronic literature or
blog blog based nonfiction and things
like that but there's some examples a
photo Pia and interactive fiction work
actually they began work on doing a film
version of that but it didn't continue
well don't be shy in the meanwhile I
have a sort of general question to pose
to our panels while we're waiting for
other questioners one way to describe at
least my experience of today's events is
to say that we began sort of elegiac Lee
with references to the decaying beauty
of this old dead tree technology and
some of the complexities of the the the
haptic or the tactile dimension of books
the aura that comes upon one when one
picks up an old volume and feels the the
force of history in it or the force of
particular authors in it so there was a
kind of partly elegiac node in the
beginning and now we've moved into a
kind of utopian mode in which what we're
thinking about our future possibilities
and new forms of expression that are now
fundamentally enabled by the digital
technologies and I'm wondering if
there's a way for us to to to identify
these two strains in the discourse about
the book and whether the panelists think
this is a useful distinction what I have
in mind is the way in which we can use
digital technology that has been implied
in some of the things that were said
earlier today the ways in which we can
use digital technologies to enhance save
and and and and and preserve what we
might call the print inheritance the way
in which these new technologies either
give us new ways for it for for saving
and transmitting the old culture the Oh
as one sort of side of the equation and
I sometimes feel that this aspect of it
is somehow because it's not sort of
exciting for technologists that it may
be less attention is paid to it but
there were certainly discussions of that
kind of tendency this afternoon and the
other the other tendency is to talk
about the kind of thing that I think is
implicit in what both Kate and Rita were
saying today that the new technologies
create possibilities have affordances as
they say that create unique
possibilities for different forms of
creativity my question is do you think
we need to choose between the two
because very often you hear the utopians
being impatient with the old humanists
who want to sort of be sure that that we
should discover new ways of recovering
preserving and studying Melville's
marginalia
right that both enterprises seem to me
valuable but I'm I'm wondering how that
how the panel feels about it or whether
the formulation is too reductive to be
useful don't be afraid to say that one
thing that I see happening in
contemporary literature our writers like
Daniel F ski I think Steven Hauk had
fall in this category as well who are
reasserting the possibilities of the
Codex in the digital age so Daniel f ski
is very adamant that he is writing a
codex he s had multiple film offers for
house of leaves for example all of which
he's turned down because he sees himself
as a print author but in situating his
work within context cultural context
dominated by digital media his work is
also transforming so for example only
revolutions which Rita mentioned is in
part a database novel and so you can see
the imprint of digital technologies on
that same thing as true of house of
leaves so even those writers who are
reasserting the importance the
centrality and the endless possibilities
of the Codex are also transforming the
form in the very act of
engaging the context in which they want
to say that codex is still important so
the so we shouldn't embrace this rigid
distinction but recognize that both both
sides of the equation can can come
together in certain practices I think
that was Rita's point in talking about
the expanded field my own term for that
phenomenon is a distributed literary
system distributed literary system that
includes a print codex but has many
other aspects as well some of which are
digital no question one one aspect of
what you're saying has to do with the I
guess for me the or maybe another way of
saying what you're saying is the idea of
open-endedness is if the that the one
way we think of older books is that they
come to a conclusion that they're over
and the implication of even an older
book being put in these new platforms
and having all this discourse around it
is to say that it even that text is no
longer singular or or or completed as if
it has a kind not just an afterlife but
an ongoing continuing life I mean I
think I think one wants to be cautious
about the polarization of that
conversation in terms of print on the
one hand of digital and the other such
that they're imagined to be self same
and identical to each other and almost
an isomorphic relation I think the
textual field is much more complex than
that and in fact the volume that
Katherine Hayles is editing with Jessica
Pressman on comparative textual media
speaks to the whole range of textual
formats from papyrus I believe to the
print what I notice about the
conversations about the about the crisis
so to speak of the book is that they
tend to be anecdotal and and indeed we
saw a lot of that this morning about
subjective impressions subjective
experiences of the loss of the book or
the the disappearance of the library and
so forth and I think the anecdotal is
very good for practice
it helps us decide what we want to do
with our libraries our card catalogs
I think it's not as good for theory it's
not as good for understanding what's
actually happening
well to just speak to the dichotomy of
printed digital which we hear so much
about now I think it's useful to
recognize that print technology today is
digital that it's more correct to say
that books are a particular output form
of digital technologies than it is to
separate it off as if it were a separate
arena and in fact I think it's very
important to recognize that print
technology itself has got one thing it's
undergone these ethical shifts all the
way from movable type to offset
lithography to digital production such
as we have in the present so I would
like to see these binaries broken up
discussed in more nuanced terms that are
more responsive to the technologies that
produce that and we had a wonderful
example of that this morning and Bonnie
Mac's presentation and others and to be
more specific about what we mean both
with print and digital yes okay I just
want to set this up a tiny bit by asking
you to clarify and this is for everyone
really just when you say book what I
mean I get the impression that what is
being meant by book is like a narrative
or a story like when we a novel
typically but I mean there are also
other things that we get in print that
are not intended to be consumed as that
exact object I mean you you have printed
screenplays you have printed plays then
there's a wide variety of other forms
that have different kind of models of
agency with respect to reading and I was
just wondering if any any of you three
could kind of speculate about this
because I mean it's a question that I've
been wrestling with it but I mean trying
to adapt the model of literary agency
where you have readers trying to
interpret what an author is saying to
more interactive forms even if those
aren't necessarily in digital forms I
mean there are other models that we
could kind of bring to it I mean if you
look at the way that plays are
constructed that you don't I mean there
are a lot of different kind of
spaces where agency happens in that and
I was just wondering if any of you had
thoughts on like agency and reading well
I think that's a useful correction to
say that not all codex books are our
novels that there's a whole variety of
productions in what we recognize as the
codex form and I also think you're
absolutely right in pointing to
different reading practices that
different kind of communities will bring
to the codex depending on the content of
that codex yeah the books that are full
of random numbers have to be approached
differently I think but also actually
you know manuals and books that are
intended to help people understand
systems to learn and to approach things
through programming or doing
calculations doing exercises and and and
working out and solving right so there
there I and this is this is one thing
that obviously books have served you
know very very well in that role and you
know there there were there's there's a
a very fascinating relationship to the
ways that you know whole books full of
not just one line programs but very
lengthy basic programs for people to
type in the the way in which those
programs in a time where it's not
convenient for people to email something
in how they actually get printed how
they get sent in by contributors and
users what types of requirements and and
are placed on there so the way that
early user communities worked and
communicated with each other had a great
deal to do with print and as I've
mentioned in some other contexts the way
that people interact with computers has
a lot to do with ink and paper or
thermal paper in some cases because
print terminals were very
frequent in use in the mid 1970s for
instance and before and so this wasn't a
screen but but actually print sometimes
inning ending up as I saw you know with
one transcript of someone's playing Zork
here at MIT in 1980 at senior house
ending up getting bound into you know
something very codecs like that
contained the transcript of that play a
question I don't think I know this did
you do any anthropological work or did
your team do any anthropological work on
the original coding in other words how
wide of a field do you articulate for
this single line does it include the
programmers at the time as well as the
the now do you do any sort of Auto
ethnography where you talk about your
own executions
I'm vigorously non anthropological in my
approach are there any people involved I
guess is another way of putting it I
mean one of the things that we that we
did know I mean we're really we're
looking at this artifact of code itself
as our focus and not as not trying to
discern for instance processes at
Commodore at the time that led to its
being included in in the book but really
trying to interpret that in in a more
literary sort of mode what we did is we
did have practice based analysis of this
program that involves writing variations
of it to see what slight changes in the
code would look like porting it to see
what it could or couldn't do on a
platform like the Apple 2 or in Perl or
JavaScript you know so on so so we tried
to use protein but the purpose of that
was not to see how we what vernacular
theories we ourselves formed about this
but rather to to understand that through
the and the technology of it through
practice so those are those are
certainly those so-called
anthropological approaches are certainly
legitimate ones to take
but that was the way that we approached
it because of the group of people who
responded to my original message about
this question over here I think it's the
left first I think you you want to wait
again I'm in college anyway I was
thinking a little bit about how you guys
were describing you in the form of the
book and then it occurred to me that
really the change that's happened is
that now that their boundaries they're
the realm of their narrative where their
story with their fiction with it I don't
even know what do you want to call it
anymore but is now infinite if that if
that kind of fit direction that you saw
this moving or do you think that there
is ultimately you just want to boundary
with a beginning and end now yes there
are yes there are boundaries there are
constraints there are definitions of the
way that different media operate when
what's possible not just technically but
culturally it's not as as much as I
enjoy utopianism sometimes it's not
manat simply a time of complete
liberation and freedom for a narrative I
mean yes well I was just thinking
concretely about Henry Jenkins work on
transmedia storytelling the expansion of
stories into fan forums and theme parks
and so forth but then so too one would
have to point to the third person the
MIT volume on epic or big narrative
diegetic universes so those two often
articulated with I mean clearly with
parameters but but nonetheless they have
the kind of scale that I think you're
gesturing toward
how are you so this is a bit of a follow
on I guess to David's question but also
something that I've been thinking about
quite a bit
so when I hear about the so called
crisis and prayers go into the mic a
little more directly some of us are
having thank you
sorry so when I hear people talk about
the crisis in print I I'm often tempted
to think actually the opposite and I
think Rita's distinction that she just
made is a very useful one if I'm
thinking from the perspective of a
business owner in the print industry or
a trained journalist who is thinking of
what the profession was like for the
last hundred years it's easy to think
about the crisis or impending doom etc
from the perspective of someone who
studies literature today I I feel like I
see the after lives of print everywhere
and particularly in the fact that the
practice of reading is so much more
present and prevalent in a world where
mobile devices internet etc are the
means through which were receiving
reading interacting with creating texts
which is to say that there's perhaps
more reading than listening and watching
than there was 50 years ago so that
makes me wonder in in my own work and
I'm interested to hear how you all think
about this you know what are the things
that actually are more relevant about
practices of reading printed texts
because of the reading practices
involved in the digital and I guess I'll
push this a little bit farther to say
that you know I'm just as skeptical as
the of the utopian narrative that comes
along with people talking about the
digital today but the one place where
I'm a bit tempted to get a bit utopian
is when I think about you know when when
in the 19th century when there were new
genres being shaped in print because of
the possibilities of the newspaper
and-and-and and cheaper print more books
there were some there was quite a bit of
utopian thinking about the communities
that could be formed as a result and
it seems to me that the parallels
between print and the digital and
reading practices provide an opportunity
to perhaps look back on those
possibilities that you know ended badly
or or however we want to interpret them
and and say well what could we learn
about the possibilities that we're all
so excited to talk about today so I
guess it's sort of two parts what
looking at we know what does what
actually makes print perhaps more
relevant to the digital and-and-and-and
would you be tempted to pick up on that
utopian thread that I just mentioned I
think in thinking about print versus
digital text of the editor from MIT who
spoke in the previous panel Gita
mentioned the issue of attention and a
lot of studies have seemed to indicate
that reading on the web is significantly
different on the whole than reading in
print and Bob Stein mentioned this also
it involves a lot more skimming and
scanning not reading complete text
reading partially a long web page for
example whereas a lot of print forms
encourage complete text reading if
you're reading an article in New
Scientist for example there's a
tradition that you would read the entire
article even if you're now accessing it
on print so one of the questions that
has interested and also concerned me is
what happens when our print tradition of
deep reading kind of collides with the
digital practices of shallow quick
skimming and scanning reading and I I
think there is there are a couple of
spin-offs of this one is the idea that
if you print up if you pick up a print
artifact you're going to spend more time
with it you're going to read it more
deeply another spin off is that you now
begin to see some transfer from digital
reading practices onto print and I think
both of those things are now sort of in
in the dynamic of reading practice
so there's this so much to say but one
of the things definitely is that I don't
think utopianism should be considered a
dirty word or a synonym for naivete if
you were talking about consciously
constructing a better society due to
increasing technological possibilities
and what that offers well yeah I think
that's a good idea
and I think I think though it takes some
some concept to take some thought about
what that really means and in this in
the case of in the case of reading
online you know for instance I think
there there were utopian ideal ist's in
the mid 1990s who feared that perhaps
Disney you know and the major networks
and so on would own the web that would
be you know what what happened we would
get Oliver that would be the information
available online in the year 2012 and
thanks to those people that didn't
happen actually we many many of us read
mostly things written by individuals
outside of corporations on blogs and
from other sources and we and that not
be the nightmare was was averted because
of positive thinking about what reading
and writing could be online and what a
meant to have a space so I'm not sure
that that address is the very narrow and
and precise concept there but it's I
think it's important to note that if we
come to these issues consciously and and
and pursue them there there are
possibilities not that technology drops
in our lap but that that we can make as
a society I suppose I would add to that
that the idea and I suppose rationale
behind the experimentation toward
increasing literacy and so forth
is not particular to print I mean we had
Bob Stein presenting what is
after all it seems to me a kind of
laboratory for experimentation - that
you would add vectors and scaler both
out of USC and an increasing range of
experimental projects that are trying in
some way to push the conventions or
traditions of print discourse into what
you might call a different space
articulated as multimodal in fact that's
what I would say is a major contribution
of electronic literature outside of
providing poetic and aesthetic effect is
that it encourages that type of deep
attention it's bringing exactly that
into the context of the web where we
have other things that are good but not
the full environment but just quickly
Kate what you're when you address this
question to start which I think this is
a very productive conversation you you
distinguished a certain amount of new
research that has shown that reading
online or reading on the screen is more
distracted unless less as you said deep
that my initial reaction as a as a
someone's born in in Long in the
pre-digital age and committed to books
in certain ways was - what was to wonder
or not wonder but to expect or to the
hope and to sort of myself insofar as
I'm capable of it even to work for the
idea that deep reading ought to also
become an experience on on in electronic
environments and there's no reason
theoretically to say that shouldn't
happen there's even some suggestion I
think that some research has been done
to say that people have begun to use
tablets more in the way they use books
and one one explanation for that may be
that the tactile element makes it more
resemble the old version of the book so
it is something that you so it seems to
me we're in very early days here and
that the these these distinctions
between types of kinds of experiences
you have online and in the old
technologies are still very permeable
and changing a great example of this
that I mentioned to you earlier is the
forthcoming iPad app for the Talmud
which is absolutely a translation of the
of deep reading and interpretive labor
and so forth to this new format well
again what we had talked about this
earlier but what if some of you may know
there's a one there's an interesting
book that sees the Talmud as a precursor
of hypertext and there are books like
the Talmud or Joyce's Ulysses that
actually seem to theoretically at least
be preferable reads in digital format
because they allow for the kinds of
connections those texts demand but that
the Codex format does not allow and I
suspect that there'll be a lot more of
that there is a digital version of
Ulysses being produced now I'm very
eager to see what comes of it because
it'll be a it'll give you access to
aspects of the books texture that a
reading of the hardcover doesn't allow
you to do Mary just as a pendant your
comment David before I ask my own
question I would want to add as an early
modernist that early modern reading was
very often not deep reading right
there's a lot of work on that the
question that I wanted to ask the
panelists is sort of about your own
reading practices so the kinds of
digital objects and texts that that you
present it on how do those figure in
your own sort of recreational
consumption you know if if you're going
to sort of go to the the equivalent of
the book store for electronic text where
do you go and how do you choose them and
do you curl up with them in the evening
and how do you consume them when you're
not doing so in a professional capacity
you can even take them into the bathtub
well the electronic literature
collection is a great place to actually
since Kate and I are editors of the
first volume with with two other
collaborators and Rita of a second
volume I mean I'd like to think we did
all that for a reason well Mary if I if
I might I'd like to respond to your
question in a kind of idiosyncratic way
that takes into account your own
presentation this morning so I gathered
that
the MIT library this space that you were
exploring is a kind of purgatory that is
the books aren't quite in the collection
they aren't quite out of the collection
they're sort of therein in some sort of
limbo that's in contrast to the UCLA
library which had a practice of selling
discard library books so you could go on
your lunch hour and you could browse the
stacks and I made a practice of doing
that and I found some absolutely amazing
finds such as Samuel Johnson's original
vision of lives of the poets for example
at another text from the Revolutionary
War so I started a recycling practice in
which I'd buy these books and then send
them to less affluent libraries that
might in fact won them for the
collection so I found some wonderful old
science fiction books and I bought those
rare editions that other science fiction
collections were missing sent them to
the people who were starting those
collections and so forth so it's just
well it's a fun little activity but in
any of it there's a kind of recycling
aspect to that I'll mention another
activity at the moment I'm teaching an
undergraduate class and distracted
reading and one of the things we do is
keep a weeklong information consumption
log modeled on the studies from UC San
Diego and even alluding to the NEA
studies and so forth
accounting for our time in counting more
specifically for again the information
we consume and produce so we keep logs
that require our counting the text
messages we send and receive and so
forth and the lesson that we've learned
is that in the end all one can do is
differentiate screen time from non
screen time that it's immaterial whether
I'm reading the New Yorker or work of
electronic literature or comment on a
particular novel blog etc what matters
is that it's within the space of the
single screen so that was a that was
actually instructive to discover it
answers the question about you know what
one does for fun because how do what
we've learned is how do you
differentiate if you're five minutes
reading ian Hatcher's to signal to know
and then browsing over to the New Yorker
browsing back to another forum etc you
can't demarcate space in the same way
which speaks to Katherine Hayles work on
attention and distraction and according
to program this part of the form is
supposed to involve all the panelists so
I would like to ask a question to press
Christian bar vikins tenían questions so
I'm so intrigued by the by the kind of
confrontation between the human and the
nonhuman in your xeno text project and
you have mentioned last night and also
today in your presentation that you're
imagining this as an ethical epoch
epochal storage that it will outlast the
human race it will outlast human
civilizations and so forth but for
VidCon Stein for language to have
meaning it has to be shared it has to
have a use context so let us suppose
that you're successful in your microbial
encoding let us suppose that a billion
years from now the microbes still exists
but human beings and human civilizations
don't who's going to read it well these
are the very same questions that could
easily asked of the Voyager probes of
the Pioneer probes of they'll persist
probably long after humans disappear who
will get to read them and how will they
be able to interpret those artifacts
it's not important what the message says
it's important that it just be there I
jokingly say that I'm really just
spray-painting graffiti on an obelisk
and that by doing so I testified who you
know the presence of a sentient response
to the world there's no way anybody's
going to be able to read a poem that's
in ciphered in that in a genome but to
signal that it's that it's there as a
that its presence is there testifies to
you know the advanced technological
civilization that you know occupied the
planet that that's
what it's about I think is is is is
pointing to that really States talking
about that to my own peer group
it's not about addressing any potential
audience of the future in the same way I
think that the Pioneer over the voyage
appropriately aren't likely ever to
address any potential audience of the
future that the probes are too small
they're only going to come within a few
light-years of any individual star and
it's unlikely I think that a
civilization would just stumble upon
them it really is a bottle thrown into
the ocean with this faint hope that we
might you know preserve some some
testament to our presence on the planet
I look at the book is something akin to
a demonic grimoire really it's an
attempt to to indulge in a much more
hellish activity you know that to assert
the influence of poetry within the
broader milieu of life itself you know
say that poetry is a way of life right
and then to try and embody it in an
actual living thing right you know to to
point to its significance at a time when
poets are insignificant
cultural contributors right you know the
most important cultural artifact that is
so far been created in terms of sheer
income is probably halo 2 which made
more money than any other cultural
artifact in human history in less than
an weekend so I yeah that that's the
world in which I have to write poetry
you know I I'm losing my market share to
online porn okay so I suppose in an
effort to to redress those kinds of
shortcomings of poetry I'm indulging in
a very hyperbolic activity it's really
all hyperbole right it's an exaggerated
experience question hi Alison cooler
again we've talked a little bit about
the way the practice of reading has
changed from the codex to the screen and
I'm very curious about the process of
writing and my own experience I've gone
from using a pen to a typewriter to a
keyboard and I know my writing has
changed through those different mediums
and I'm just wondering maybe if any of
you who've spoken today would like to
address that you know how you think the
process of
a writing has changed over the years and
what you think the consequences of that
might be down the road I can speak just
for myself on this score so I've had
quite a few years now to produce
scholarly books and one hopes that when
produced ones produces scholarship a few
people read it but I'm sort of in the
position that Christian articulated Here
I am producing scholarship that you know
maybe read for maybe a few thousand
people in my wildest dreams certainly
nothing like the production of computer
games so my latest endeavor is to create
a computer game and okay if people are
now into computer games let's explore
computer games as a medium of writing
and of literary production and what I've
discovered in that process is the way
that creative writing can flow together
with computer codes can flow together
with cryptography can flow together with
dirty little tricks we want to play on
our players and it's actually been quite
exhilarating so for me it's a radical
change in my writing practice and in the
relationship I imagine with my readers
or players in this case I can just
mention that you can all you can create
computer games and still have very few
people not to deflate anything but um
I there's a lot of fattening one of the
I think this issue of actual you know
material apparatus of writing and the
nature of the computer I mean as much as
I'm very interested in computation
itself which is why I look at a
computational artifact rather than a
networked
computer system you know in in this
recent book but a lot of uh I think a
lot of what actually transforms writing
experience for me has to do with the
network and not so much new
computational capabilities not so much
things that couldn't be done in longhand
or with a typewriter so being able to
collaborate with others online and write
in the same document at the same time or
write in a system that's tracked and
inversion like in MediaWiki is a
tremendously significant and it's it's
significant to be online or not when one
is writing to have to book tickets on a
long distance Amtrak train in order to
write without distraction because one
cannot be online you know is a different
situation
to to to be and and so I mean there are
things about you know I I write at
coffee houses and I you know there I
don't mind certain types of distraction
or certain types of environment in that
mendoza ways but but i think that that's
a big issue and in in many ways you know
writing in a cabin longhand with a
typewriter with a computer offline or
writing in a coffee house or you know
writing with a network connection the
the difference between the particular
instrument of writing that's being used
doesn't seem to me nearly as significant
so to this discussion of the inevitable
digitization of our writing practices
out just what add one other note so mark
danielewski's only revolutions for all
of the complexity of its visual layout
and certainly for all of the software
that was required in order to formulate
the page space came down to the use of
note cards for the use of the dates in
the central column so even there one
sees that won't you that there's no
there's an away no such thing as a
radical break nor would would one would
what nor would one want to think in
those terms
question hi I'm Jonathan Bohan I'm a
recent library school graduate and my
question is in this whole discussion of
distracted reading I'm wondering if
there's any consideration or thought
given to people who already have a
problem with distraction
people with AD D people with learning
disabilities there's a lot of people
with those problems and like I I have a
D D and just even trying to read
anything online I can't can't do it for
more than 20 seconds I'm on to something
else so how does that but is there any
effect on how how people would write for
for that sort of situation well what
I've noticed is a tendency among print
authors to respond to distracted reading
so a good example of that for me would
be the exploit Alexander Galloway and
Eugene Thacker
so they I'm part of their print book
they've provided short summaries so you
can actually just read the bolded lines
and get a sense of the argument and
moreover they've divided into a kind of
modular fashion so you can skip around
and still get a sense of what the book
is about so they're presuming readers
who are not going to read continuously
page after page but rather gonna skip
around are going to maybe only read the
bolded lines in some sections and so
forth so I think that distracted reading
is now becoming not just a reading
practice but cultural practice to which
writers are responding it's it's a
fascinating question what would be the
literary equivalent for Neville Dean and
Taylor for instance the directorial team
I think the closest thing we have is
Tallinn Mehmet slep Souter perplex Co
which
makes normative makes the standard the
state of perplexity so in other words
rather than thinking about a kind of
deviation from long forms of narrative
deviation from sustained practices of
attention
it makes disorientation the standard
from which one would have to imagine
that a shift back to what we now regard
as traditional forms of reading would be
the deviation just I'm compelled to make
this one comment about distracted
reading like let's say you know what
you're listening to music like as you're
reading perhaps right and that's that's
distracted reading so I mean why isn't
that distracted music listening maybe
it's the reading that's distracting you
from the other activity I mean if you
were if you were reading while you're
driving you wouldn't be like oh I'm
doing distracted reading I mean yeah
there is this media ecology which
they're you know different things are
happening and and I think I mean they
you know like unplugging the network
cable and hiding it somewhere locking it
you know I mean those are the types of
responses that by that are appropriate
if you want to actually engage with
something on a computer a piece of
interactive fiction a piece of
electronic literature or some work
without all the concomitant you know
Network sort of distractions
you can commerce 64 would be a great
system to use actually
I think to have the whole suite of
add-ons and plugins that have been
developed in order to create what one
might call a sort of page space online
readability is the most well known
example I think I understand in
California there are now slow internet
cafes where you have only a dial-up
modem and so you sit there and drink
your coffee and wait for the message to
appear on a screen
you know if you think back to the
earliest designs of word processing
programs you can see a drama like this
going on because in the very beginning
certain people who use the word
processing programs for the first time
they were obviously analog people were
very offended by even the minimal menu
that they found so also they used to
require they used to have an ad above a
choice you could make where you could
have the whole screen blanket just like
a blank paper but I think one of the
interesting things is of course how how
quickly people got used to the idea of
distractions in the margins of the page
has simply an experience of how you work
and now they rule it out
not unlike I think the way people
watching television for 40 years closed
their ears and eyes so the commercials
they were sitting in front of so I mean
I think there is a process of getting
used to process that's clearly operating
in the digital world in ways that are
changing our are our uneasiness about
the strangeness of these new
environments but in which we read and
write I have to ask how many people read
on their phone on their smartphone are
there some this is such a great oh sorry
this is such a great thing because the
that is a device that is designed to
interrupt you
its purpose is to stop you from what
you're doing so that you know you take
the phone call right I mean it's exactly
the opposite of what you would want in
in a reading device it's like having
your doorbell as a reader or you know I
mean something like no and and so it's a
system that is grow
out into a general-purpose computer if
the corporate superstructures will allow
it but but you know it there's something
about the fundamental nature of that
system whereas this what is this you
know right here it's a book I mean this
is you know how encase Dynabook the
power book your MacBook all I mean these
are these this is a notebook computer
you know wait I'm sorry on the left
first your sec your next your first I
have a night I'm curious as to who's
publishing or if that's online who is
hosting the works that miss Raley and
Miss talked about in other words like
who's publishing it was paying for it
okay so I will mention the electronic
literature collection because it has
collected together and in the mode of
anthology David Clarke's 88
constellations not Ian hatch or
signal-to-noise Talon myslexia Pro
clucks perplex a was in the first volume
so there are these collection projects
so they're not publication exactly but
but we do host so it's a kind of
Republican although the terminology
starts to fall apart a little bit at
that point and I'll just mention that
the editorial and curatorial work for
both the electronic literature
collection one and collection two was
strictly pro bono so there was never any
expectation that we any of us would make
a profit and indeed it cost us money to
produce those CDs and DVDs that went
along with two collections and many
people felt that it was redundant to
produce a DVD of electronic literature
collections but I think that was maybe
short-sighted and had in mind only a
u.s. context because when I traveled to
places like Croatia people were
extremely happy to get the DVD because
they either didn't have internet
or it was very expensive for them so I
think actually it even though it was a
negative income stream it was a quite
worthwhile project plus it allows you to
disconnect your computer from the
network while you read the electronic
literature with that being said what
sort of role do you think like an
expanded book
so with ancillary ancillary materials in
addition to just the text what role
would that expanded book play in
traditional sort or more traditional
even scholarly publishing and it is an
important question what is the
relationship between the electronic
literature community as we imagine it to
the MFA world or rather to the world of
letters industry essentially it's
certainly the case that there's no
commercial model there's no commercial
viable commercial model I always think
the iTunes model might be one that could
be adopted but it's very much there very
much amateur efforts even though there
are dedicated creative writing programs
like at Brown the MFA program where John
Cayley works that that produces MFA
students who work with computational
media nonetheless there is a sense in
which this type of writing practice is
situated outside of the economies of
literary production that have developed
over the last few centuries to me it's
quite an open question what publishing
is going to mean in the near future or
even right now so one of the things that
I wanted to do was to publish a digital
companion in my print book how we think
that it's coming out very shortly and I
said I wrote a grant proposal to get
some money to do this part of the grant
proposal required me to state my plans
to publish it and I thought about that
so I'm going to host the site I'm going
to pay for this site what would it mean
for the university of chicago press to
publish this work as far as I could
figure out what it would mean is that
they
would put their name on it I was doing
all the work I was hosting it why in
fact what I want them to put their name
on maybe I do want them to put their
name on it I take that back
but you see the you see the issue here
when you start publishing things
yourself what is the role of the press
or the University Press in particular
and this morning we heard Gaeta make an
argument that the the role of the
University Press is to maintain
editorial control but then we heard Bob
Stein say well everybody now can be an
editor I expect that the very fine job
that editors like prestige presses like
MIT do is not going to be done as well
by general public type people who may
choose to serve as editors at Bob Stein
but we live in an age now where hardly
anybody except Christian Bach takes 10
years to write a book useful scholarly
lifetime of a book now is about three
years and so is there really a point to
have these polished jewels where immense
amounts of editorial work go into them
when the lifetime the useful scholarly
lifetime of books is increasingly
diminishing I can see an argument for
saying open up the editorial floodgates
let everybody be an editor
yes quality standards will go down but
you'll get a lot more books and maybe
it's a it's a offset to have many more
books with less careful editorship and
curation than it is to have scholarly
presses maintain a kind of funnel effect
on what gets published and I would
invite Peter now to respond in
particular one quick note this seems
like the sort of economic question here
is how this kind of work gets funded and
David Clarke's work is funded by grants
from the Canadian Council for the Arts
and it does seem their large arts
organizations
Canada that are funding fantastic
projects Christians work has also
benefited from large grants I don't know
of comfortable institutions in the US
that are funding at least the digital
humanities are incredibly well funded in
the US I'm not sure about digital
artworks and the granting foundations
for that sort of endeavor just a side
note I think you're right I think
there's a market scarcity of such
agencies in the u.s. uh yeah thank you
for that question Kate I wanted to
respond by saying that we're asking
similar questions about it so everyone
can stand up so people where we're
asking very similar questions at the MIT
press about the usefulness of the highly
reviewed highly edited highly polished
monograph and is that something that
it's still valued is it something that
we still want to invest so many
resources in and I think right now we do
we are willing to make that investment
for the record for scholarship for the
future but that doesn't in any way
conflict with your point that other
people can be editors as well one's own
scholarly community can edit one's work
and and and and that can be a very
productive process that can complement
what we do as University Press editors
so if you came to me with a project that
your community had vetted and whose
quality it had established and and and
if that community had given you useful
advice for revising the work and you
brought it to me at that point after
you'd made that those revisions I would
say do I have any remaining questions as
as an editor about this work and can I
get those answered by consulting more
people or is this ready to go my
questions at that point might be more
commercial they might be you know about
who was the audience for this work and I
might want to do additional review to
determine that we have only a few
minutes left so let me ask the audience
to be succinct and
the panelists to be equally succinct
think of it as a sort of final lightning
round
I love Keita's refreshing as a publisher
refreshing view of the ambiguity of the
costing and economics we're in such a
volatile interplay between the two
displays paper and screen for the one
umbrella book that we we have to kind of
look a look around for other models I
just want to offer one very briefly
paper making and printing emerged as
completely autonomous crafts for
completely different agendas
one was a debossing useful for making
pilgrim badges and the other was a
substitute for textiles
well what occurred was that those two
independent technologies began slowly to
merge and in fact by the 18th and 19th
century you could not distinguish the
product of paper from the product of
print in publication think of a circus
broadside or a daily newspaper so they
not only emerge but came became a third
phenomena and technology of their own
and even that merge the printing always
gets the most attention because it's
construed because it's it's more
directly a conveyor of content its
construed as a high domination of
transitions in politics and and
ideologies and in literature but papers
never mentioned because it doesn't have
that same immediate relationship with
content
Cheers here's the kicker there's a third
factor that was even more crucial than
the merge of paper and printing it was
the commodification of books
commercially by book binders remember
printers only print sheets of paper they
don't make books so commodification
stages have to be fulfilled and played
out as well so I'm offering that that's
an earlier model that can be brought to
the functionality of the relationship of
the two displays of paper and screen in
books yes next question I just have a
very quick question it seems to me that
there should be something like a wake I
mean a celebration like we should be
dancing in the streets we should be
drinking champagne celebrating the death
of the print book and I mean I'm being
perhaps provocative here but I cannot
think of a single negative aspect of the
decline of the print book and I'll just
give you a quick example of two things
that might be person that that might be
perceived as negative on the one hand
private entities have difficulty making
profit but doesn't the the free flow of
information far outweigh the cost that
gatekeepers have difficulty obtaining
profit and the second issue has to do
with this idea of distracted reading
there's work on embodied cognition and
really I think what's going on is rather
than distract reading is that the
computer the tablet is actually part of
our cognition or long-term memory stored
in this and I'll just give a very quick
example if you look at the Flynn effect
IQ points have increased over the past
70 years and the dominant explanation is
that you know we actually have this sort
of distributed cognition with the
computer so I would like to hear the
panelists response just the one-word
response to the first part of your
comment No
I can give the fun my question is the
seven word response to that more or less
but and here's the in here's really the
question that the sisters felt about
everything that gets said beginning to
the end of the conference we started off
looking at two thousand-year-old books
that we can read today we have
Christians that nobody will be able to
read in a billion years and because it
won't be anybody to read it if it ever
happens and sight which it doesn't
matter what it says that it could be
saying nothing now if we actually have
some content that's worth keeping
perhaps the electronic literature that's
being created today in media that in
five years will dissolve or our fugitive
or not be able to be read or go the way
of all of the other eight tracks and
stuff or what do we have in terms of the
creative work that's being done now
electronically that's going to ensure
the readability of it the same way that
that book that he wants to get rid of
can be read another two thousand years
the same book that we read two thousand
years ago well if you carve that text in
stone it would last even longer I mean
there's different systems for different
things it's it's you know not the care
this this program is in a book that will
last a long time and you know so there
there are there are ways to to address
those questions as authors as creators
of work as preservationist but there are
also different things that different
objects do culturally and I think one of
the things about the reason that we
shouldn't be having a revel at the
demise of the book aside from the fact
that it's not dead is it has to do with
all of the cultural history and cultural
cognition that's wrapped up in the
development of that book and what it
means and the along with things like
perhaps oppressive regimes and concepts
of authorship and copyright and so you
know but also very positive things and
so we have the chance now to pick those
things out and to figure out in in that
utopian mode you know what if this
do we want to bring into the next
version of the book I mean just it's
worth mentioning that the electronic
literature organization has devoted a
lot of time and energy to thinking about
this problem and I think I saw on the
table out there a copy of the white
paper on the preservation archiving
dissemination initiative if not yet free
bits is out there this should be several
copy still that are free for the taking
so it's something that we've looked into
but that that's not the single metric
for the value of a medium the the the
duration of time that it preserves a
message I mean it's one of the things in
a cultural system you know that is worth
considering along with a lot of other
factors
final question final comment so wonder
one of the sort of more dystopian things
that disturbs me that nobody has brought
up is just how much of the digital
record is proprietary and how the
digital has actually fostered that and
just what what a tremendous amount of
scholarship is behind paywalls
and you know the libraries that are
paying millions and millions of dollars
for this material and the ebooks that
we're buying to replace print are less
accessible they're they have really
heavy DRM they can't be shared they
can't they can barely be printed they're
much more difficult to use than printed
books and so I just wanted to throw that
out there as a tempering yeah as a
practical matter yes you know one of the
responses is both volumes of the
electronic literature collection are
Creative Commons licensed and you can
take those discs that are out there for
you to get for free and copy them to
your hard drive if you like and and and
distribute them you know otherwise you
you mean so we that this is one way you
know actively that we that we try to
deal with this from the standpoint of
our realm of practice and criticism of
looking at electronic literature it's a
very severe issue it's it's the type of
thing that that people in the mid 90s
concerned about the web you know or
dealing with
and and this and and and the question of
should we embrace the commodification of
the book as a critical point I think
bears on this issue do we need a
proprietary model for what the book will
be no I don't think so that's why I run
free software and that's why right
that's why my own callers need to help
us basically I mean it's not a thing to
just create your new scholarship in open
as Omen open access what you really need
to do is help work against the current
system in which thousands and thousands
of academic journals are just locked up
yes sign up at the cost of knowledge
com2 opposed Elsevier and work too but I
think starting with work and one's own
practice and making it available 10
print the book that I'm doing with nine
others thanks to the MIT press will be
Creative Commons license it's going to
be made available in digital version for
free online it will also be a beautiful
book object that it will be two color
printed with custom end papers and will
be very carefully designed laid out to
the advantage of someone who wishes to
read that version I mean this is but but
I don't think you should stop it you
know making your own work Creative
Commons or otherwise opening it I think
that it does need to be addressed
institutionally it's it's a very serious
issue and we're in a situation where
libraries I mean MIT doesn't pay for
bundling but other people don't have the
same other other institutions they don't
have the same sorts of of advantages
that there are they're greatly
restricted in in what can be done with
the scholarly record that's you know
paid for by institutions volunteer labor
of people I could go on for a while but
we need to stop I'd like to thank the
audience and thank the panelists
[Applause]